véronique souhaite prendre des vacances
elle cherche en ligne et trouve un
billet très bon fit pour s'envoler vers
le sud
la veille du départ elle remplit sa
demande d'enregistrement mauvaise
surprise le prix de son billet
n'incluait pas ses bagages elle devra
payer 25 $ pour chaque valise mis en
soute
ce qui veut dire le double pour l'aller
et le retour non pourtant véronique est
certaine qu'on n'a pas informé de ce
montant au moment de la réservation
elle retourne sur le site de la
compagnie et constate qu'il est écrit en
petits caractères des frais
supplémentaires pourraient s'appliquer
emporté par son enthousiasme véronique
n'avait pas pris le temps de les lire
elle n'aura pas le choix de payer pour
ses bagages en soute la loi sur la
protection du consommateur prévoit qu'un
bagage peut être considérée comme
optionnel ces frais n'ont donc pas à
être inclus dans le prix et bien entendu
certaines compagnies ne se fonde pas en
quatre pour vous en informer
le fin mot de l'histoire avant de
cliquer sur une offre exceptionnelle
assurez vous que le transport des
valises n'est pas optionnelle